many of you are probably getting ready
to buy your ingredients for a holiday
feast maybe you're going to splurge on a
steak prime rib maybe a roast but meat
prices are continuing to soar and
butcher shops are already feeling the
impact victoria saha joining us now live
in studio with more on some of the
changes that could be coming victoria
cities we're seeing prices go up in
almost every aisle at the grocery store
according to the department of labor
produce is four percent more expensive
compared to last year cereal and bakery
products even higher but the largest
increase is for meat and eggs
check that out 12
and for many the meat is the centerpiece
dish for the holidays
meat prices are steering in the wrong
direction
that's the price of two prime ribs a lot
higher than what it was a year ago at
butcher block the price of prime ribs
were 19.99 a pound last year now you'll
be paying at least 27.99 a pound i'm on
the phone constantly with my providers
and my purveyors and they don't see a
decrease yet anytime soon either owner
ron lutz is doing what he can to charge
his customers a fair price while he pays
more to his meat suppliers in nebraska
the industry as a whole is really short
staffed but to his surprise the
rocketing prices aren't turning people
away when shopping for their holiday
feast top sirloin and a filet it's just
something that you just have to budget
in and get used to and accept it and
just keep buying customers like aaron
manfredi are willing to pay more for the
quality i treat it like a delicacy
soaring gas prices along with the
shortage of laborers feeding into the
increase in meat prices nevada has no
processing facilities and so everything
that we bring in has to come from
someplace else since we may not see an
end in sight anytime soon doug busselman
with the nevada farm bureau says they're
trying to build a local meat processing
plant
beef doesn't have to be your only option
this holiday season lutz says he has
turkeys and hams that haven't been
impacted too much by the price hike
another reason for the issue the
devastating weather in the midwest
that's destroying lots of ranches and
farms denise